ich bin wieder da Alter
ja wie wunderbar es funktioniert oh mein
Gott es hängt sieht da hinten richtig
wie es am Regnen ist
ganz genau sehen es wird nur schlimmer
ausgesetzt in der Wildnis von Schweden
kämpft ein Mann sieben Tage mit sieben
Gegenständen ums Überleben ich bin
wieder da der erste Versuch endete für
den outdoor-neuling schnell
Sport und Helme waren ihm dadurch sicher
doch jetzt ist er zurück an dem Ort an
dem alles begann die Wiedergutmachung
keine Kamerateam Jetzt Geht's Ab keinen
Kontakt zur Außenwelt
vollkommene Isolation
herzlich Willkommen zu Games seven
okay Stopp bevor wir mit der zweiten
Folge weitermachen möchte ich euch daran
erinnern dass am 2 Oktober Deadline für
alle Steuererklärungen in Deutschland
ist doch keine Panik mit taxfix dem
Partner des heutigen Videos ist das
nicht nur super einfach aus der Welt zu
schaffen sondern außerdem springt für 9
von 10 von euch Steuerrückerstattung von
durchschnittlich 1.095 € pro Jahr dabei
rum steuern können wirklich
Kopfschmerzen bereiten das weiß ich das
schöne ist mittagsfix gehören
komplizierte Steuererklärung der
Vergangenheit an und ihr könnt sie auch
ohne großes Vorwissen ablegen und dann
tatsächlich mal abwickeln und wirklich
was zurückbekommen anstatt dass wir die
letzten Jahre einfach links liegen zu
lassen und komplett auf eure
Steuerrückzahlung zu verzichten Tag fix
ist dabei die Schnittstelle zwischen
euch und dem Finanzamt anhand von
simplen Fragen geht Tags fix alles
Wesentliche mit euch durch um das
Maximale aus eurer Steuererklärung
rauszuholen das Beste ist während ihr
euch durch die paar Fragen durch klickt
gibt es zu jedem komplizierten Thema
eine einfache Erklärung was ich lästiges
Google und suchen erspart dabei könnt
ihr frei wählen ob ihr das über den
Browser am Rechner oder die App auf dem
Handy macht und das lästige Thema von
überall entspannt angeht habt ihr alles
Nötige ausgefüllt und hochgeladen heißt
es nur noch auf Absenden drücken den
Service einmalig für 39 € und 99 Cent
kaufen die Füße hochlegen und entspannt
auf eure Rückzahlung mit
durchschnittlicher Höhe von 1.95 € war
also holt euch jetzt auf den letzten
Drücker noch mittagsfix das von der
Steuer zurück was euch zusteht checkt
also den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung und spart als
Neukunden mit dem Code Dave 5 € auf eure
nächste Steuererklärung vielen Dank fürs
möglich machen dieser Reihe und euch
viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video
ich habe einfach durchgepennt
ein absoluter Traum ich liege in meiner
eigenen Suppe das merke ich auch schon
also obwohl mir jetzt nicht ultra warm
ist
habe ich die Sachen jetzt schon 24
Stunden an und das merkt man und
das alles jetzt noch sechs Mal ich lasse
mich aber nicht verarschen ich weiß
natürlich dass jetzt draußen wieder
diese ganzen Scheiß Viecher unterwegs
sind deswegen bleibe ich noch liegen ich
kann außerdem nach wie vor nicht
einschätzen 5 Uhr 6 Uhr 7 Uhr 8 Uhr
keine Ahnung auf jeden Fall ist es schon
wieder leicht hell so dass jemand
übrigens mein Setup einfach komplett mit
Klamotten gepennt
dementsprechend ist alles so ein
bisschen feucht also nicht mal von außen
sondern einfach so von so ein bisschen
Schweiß und so weiter ich glaube jetzt
mein Tab auf ähm hängt draußen mein
Schlafsack komplett zum trocknen und
dann kann hier auch einmal alles
durchlüften und trocknen und ähm mach
mich dann so ein bisschen einen Körper
hygien oder was auch immer die
vielleicht sogar komplett schwimmen
keine Ahnung schauen wir mal
[Musik]
schaut mal wie krass das funktioniert
hat genau bis hierhin war das Tab hier
drin ist alles komplett trocken hier
draußen ist alles nass
das lässt sich das hier schön alles
wieder durchtrocknen hole die Sachen
hier gleich raus kann als allererstes
gehe ich zum See und erledige was zu
erledigen ist
mittlerweile laufe ich wirklich immer am
Morgen her einfach weil ihr kein hohes
Gras ist da ist die Hose sofort nass und
dann den Füßen aber hier
für drei Meter breiten Abschnitt einfach
keinen Gras die kann nicht perfekt
Richtung Wasser laufen besser geht's
nicht Alter hier ist ein Strand
Alter
niemand unterwegs aber hin und wieder
kommen kann Nuten vorbei
sie zumindest so aus ich habe noch keine
gesehen
[Musik]
Tag Nummer zwei jeder weiß es bedeutet
Challenge Nummer eins die richtige
Challenge gestern war es ja hin
schwimmen wir haben genau wie in der
ersten Staffel schön in diesen schwarzen
bags und ich weiß dass challenges gibt
und ich habe auch noch so grob im Kopf
was es war aber ich weiß nicht mehr was
für heute dran ist Fackel bauen wäre
geil weil ich habe das ganze Material
hier halt noch nicht verbrannt da könnte
ich mir ordentlich Zeit nehmen
aha
jetzt kommt green senden blablabla
ich pack mein Handy immer noch weg
und ich habe Glück es werde Licht deine
Aufgabe baue eine Fackel aus natürlichen
Materialien die Fackel darf maximal an
der breitesten Stelle 50 cm lang sein
und der Umfang an der breitesten Stelle
nicht mehr als 40 cm zum Essen benutzte
das beigelegte Maßband sowie die
Stoppuhr Filmen die Maße mit der Kamera
ab aber du hast nur bis zum
Sonnenuntergang Zeit zu bauen und zu
testen die Fackel muss eigenständig
stehen und brennen brennt die Fackel
einmal darfst du sie nicht mehr berühren
oder verändern Stoppuhr Maßband Stift
und hier auf dem Zettel wird das
eingetragen
ich glaube genau darum kümmern wir uns
jetzt als erstes ich habe gerade gesehen
ich habe gestern hier schon so eine
Astgabel gefunden die hier hingelegt
vielleicht
nutze ich das
um da Sachen zwischenzuklemmen
dann kann ich die auch natürlich hier
unten abschneiden in den Boden stecken
dann messen bis wo der 40 cm Umfang ist
mir quasi erlaubt dass hier zu machen
das könnte ich als erstes mal testen ich
glaube das mache ich
ich hoffe das war jetzt nicht zu kurz
die Frage ist wie kriege ich die Sachen
da drin fest sobald die brennt darf ich
nichts mehr verändern
bedeutet die Sachen müssen so fest sein
dass auch wenn irgendwas abfackelt das
nicht rumrutscht und dann irgendwie
rausfällt weiß ich ja nicht ob das hier
so die richtige Wahl ist
vielleicht ist es doch eher in
Schwedenfeuer dafür müsste ich aber noch
ein vernünftigen Stamm suchen
hier
39 cm das passt also
schneide ich den da ab
wunderbar
ich habe schon wirklich keine Energie
nach dem Tag ohne Essen
jedes bisschen Bewegung zerrt so an den
Kräften
ist echt krass
time to break
da wollen wir mal
ein beherzter Tritt oder was
eine Seite gut ja das war jetzt
wichtiges Holz
ein bisschen dumm
und dann muss ich erstmal Ruhe geben
aber das sieht schön trocken aus
eigentlich
und wieder wichtiges Holz verloren
egal
oh mein Gott
das Messer ist gebrochen
[Musik]
es hält noch an
an einer Niete
durch
durch nur noch diese Niete
[Musik]
ja
hiermit werde ich jetzt genau gar nichts
mehr machen außer zu schnitzen
wie kriege ich diesen Scheiß Stamm oh
mein Gott
zwei
[Musik]
eins ist klar dieser scheiß Klotz hat
mich mein Messer gekostet für die
nächsten fünfeinhalb Tage ich bin jetzt
anderthalb Tage hier draußen eine Nacht
und habe keinen brauchbares Messer mehr
also nicht so richtig zwei Option
bleiben mir gerade äh glaube ich dieses
Ding aufspalten übelst viel Zeug rein
klemmen und das Anzünden oder alles hier
zwischen Klemmen da muss ich nicht
spalten aber das Ding hier wird
auseinanderfallen in dem Moment wo es
brennt darf ich ja nichts mehr machen
das bedeutet wir Spalten dieses Ding und
hoffen dass es funktioniert
50 cm
diese Scheiße ist wirklich
durchgebrochen Alter dieses
drecksmesser
120 Euro oder was kostet die Scheiße
jetzt kannst du keinem erzählen
schaut mal so
und dann noch einiges mehr an Zeug da
rein
dann habe ich 20 cm so 20 cm so zurück
das Messer dicker was für eine Scheiße
und dann Meter machen andere Taktik ich
habe was im Kopf
ich flache die hier ab
so dass die da möglichst wenig Platz
brauchen und dann stecke ich so viele
wie es geht hier so rein und mache hier
so einen Busch
mit
diesem tollen Messer mache ich das was
denn sonst
packe an der Klinge das ist so dumm
was soll ich machen
aha
wisst ihr was
ich muss es so versuchen
ich starte einfach mal
okay um ehrlich zu sein fühlt es sich so
an als würde sie brennen
vielleicht ist aber auch bisher nur
Zunder
eine Minute voll
ich habe mir was ganz anderes erhofft
muss ich ehrlich sein ganz anderen
Aufbau aber es funktioniert das ist
einzige worum es geht
ich denke man könnte das noch weiter
hinauszögern
aber das ist eine Zeit mit der ich sehr
zufrieden bin sehr zufrieden
ich glaube ich kümmere mich mal um Loch
um die ganze Scheiße zu beseitigen
ich habe das einfach komplett lost ich
habe das Feuer einfach angemacht ohne
mich vorher darum zu kümmern hier alles
abzusichern sehr dumm
so jetzt wird ein bisschen geräuchert
also hoffentlich
sorgt das nicht für
Aufsehen im Sinne von Feuerwehr oder so
weil das schlägt jetzt schon ordentliche
Wolken ich habe einfach hier Zeug was in
der Nähe lag genommen und drauf
geschmissen
ja schauen wir mal
kleines Feuerchen
also ganz ehrlich
man ist schon einsam
aber vielleicht ist es genau das was ich
in meinem aktuellen Leben gebraucht habe
einfach Ruhe keinen Stress
niemandem Antworten einfach alleine mit
sich selber sein und
einfache Arbeit machen im Sinne von
welches Holz nehme ich was brennt Feuer
oder nicht Feuer was funktioniert
ich habe schon das Gefühl jetzt nach
zwei Tagen das ist ein wirklich grounded
und das mir wirklich gut tut
obwohl ich auch Entzügen natürlich schon
keinen Bock mehr habe gerade wenn so
Sachen wie die Fackel heute morgen nicht
funktionieren
würde ich am liebsten meine Sachen
packen und einfach einfach gehen so also
in meinem traumszenario bilden diese
drei Bäume das Gestell für mein neues
Holzlager warum weil ich habe Lust zu
bauen und ich habe paracordt und für die
nächste Challenge muss ich ja bis morgen
warten das bedeutet ich mache hier eine
Lattung und da eine Lattung weil der
Wind kommt genau von da so würde der
Wind mit Regen voll auf meinen auf mein
Holz prasseln aber in diese Richtung das
Holz geöffnet
geht okay komplett neue Idee ich mache
hier so eine Querverstrebung hin und
nutze das Paracord was ich hier schon
habe um mein Tab abzuspannen das
bedeutet ich kann dieses Ding festmachen
ohne Paracord zu nutzen und kann dann
hier solche Querlatten benutzen um das
dahin zu machen und auf der anderen
Seite genauso und macht dann hier
drunter mein Holzlager
[Musik]
hier ist schön zu laufen
kein hohes Gras wo man nass wird und
nicht so sandig hier am Strand
perfekt eigentlich jo
keine Ahnung von wem das ist oder das
oder das oder das das hier sieht um
ehrlich zu sein gar nicht so klein aus
jetzt gerade so drüber nachdenke
könnte das von der Größe her schon so
also nicht die kleinen Haufen aber die
großen
zu einem Hund artigen Wesen passen
will ich nicht hoffen dass es zu
hundartig in Richtung Wolf ist
so Nacht Nummer zwei startet es wird
endlich dunkel endlich geht der zweite
Tag zu Ende es zieht sich und zieht sich
und zieht sich es macht eine Menge Bock
ähm gerade tagsüber haben wir jetzt echt
echt viel hinbekommen und ich habe geile
Pläne für die nächsten Tage immer noch
wenig Lust auf die Nächte besonders
nachdem ich gerade eben die Scheißhaufen
gefunden habe die ich natürlich nicht
zuordnen kann weil ich kein Profi bin
und ich hoffe dass es jetzt nicht so
regnen nicht so krass regnet aber ich
habe irgendwie das Gefühl dass diese
Nacht krass wird
Alter es ist komm komplett am Regnen
seit Stunden
aber es ist trocken
und wir mitten in der Nacht glaube ich
[Applaus]
ja und wir in meiner Stimme hört ich bin
nicht erst gerade aufgewacht
aber ich komme gut klar
so guten Morgen Ich bin wieder da Tag
Nummer 3 ich habe bis auf eine kurze
Einlage von der ich nicht mehr weiß ob
ich sie nachts festgehalten habe quasi
durchgepennt es ist richtig ordentlich
Regen runtergekommen es ist richtig viel
Zeug richtig nass heute wird das Camp
richtig weiter gebaut und ich glaube
dass wir heute auch endlich mal darüber
sprechen warum ich wirklich in Staffel 1
so früh ausgeschieden bin aber erstmal
ins Bad
gerade aufgestanden und der Regen geht
sofort wieder los
ah
man muss überlegen ich habe noch nicht
mal die Hälfte geschafft
[Applaus]
keine Ahnung wie das Wetter in den
nächsten Tagen wird wenn das die ganze
Zeit so ist dann bin ich richtig
wieder auf
so Challenge Tag Nummer 3
ich frag mich ob es heute schon floss
bauen ist ich weiß es nicht mehr
Challenge Teil 3 weniger ist mehr deine
Aufgabe erledige dich überflüssige
Ausrüstung was überflüssig ist
entscheidest du ein Kleidungsstück gibt
einen Punkt ein Gegenstand gibt zwei
Punkte verstauer alle abgegebenen
Gegenstände in den blauen Packsack und
versiegele ihn mit der Blombe die sich
im Umschlag befindet wichtig die
Gegenstände müssen genauso abgegeben
werden wie sie beim Start vorgefunden
wurden ist der Park sagt einmal
verschlossen dafür nicht mehr geöffnet
werden wir starten bei Klamotten und
zwar ganz unten Schuhe gebe ich nicht ab
auf keinen Fall offensichtlich Socken
wäre eine Möglichkeit macht aber glaube
ich auch überhaupt keinen Sinn weil die
meine Füße wärmen auch bei Nacht auch im
Schlafsack Hose macht keinen Sinn
Unterhose könnte gehen wird dann aber
unangenehm für die nächsten Tage
T-Shirt
sehe ich nicht
Pullover wärmend sehe ich auch nicht
Regenjacke sehe ich würde für mich
bedeuten keinen Fuß mehr raussetzen wenn
es regnet und nur unterm Tat bleiben das
geht und Kappe abgeben geht auch weil
ich diese Kapuze habe ich habe dann
nichts mehr was mich von oben auch ein
bisschen bei Regen schützt das hier
würde mich bei Regen schützen und die
Regenjacke eben auch aber das beides
nicht Gegenstände Tag Paracord
Hängematte Schlafsack Feuerzeug Messer
Säge Messer ist kaputt könnte man
abgeben ist aber nach wie vor scharf und
kann man irgendwie benutzen
Säge macht schon Sinn um Meter zu machen
für Holz
komme ich aber vielleicht ohne klar also
Säge halten wir im Hinterkopf Schlafsack
gebe ich auf keinen Fall ab gebe ich auf
keinen Fall ab Hängematte gebe ich auf
keinen Fall ab und Feuer gebe ich auch
auf keinen Fall ab
ich hätte jetzt gerade noch mal ein
bisschen überlegt gestern die Challenge
ging bis Sonnenuntergang ich gehe davon
aus dass alle anderen Challenge ist auch
bis Sonnenuntergang gehen und ich meine
mich auch zu erinnern dass in Staffel 1
das zum Sonnenuntergang abgegeben wurde
ich kann es jetzt nicht nachprüfen ich
kann es nicht nachforschen aber es fühlt
sich richtig an also
benutze ich die Sachen jetzt noch für
heute und gebe sie heute Abend zum
Sonnenuntergang ab und
verschließt den Packsack
[Musik]
folgendermaßen sieht das jetzt aus hier
das abgedeckt ich werde da das noch
weiter abdecken aber unten ist glaube
ich nicht so mega wichtig also da müsste
der Wind schon super krass stehen dass
das da unten rein pfeifen kann ist
wichtiger von oben da kommt noch mehr
drauf ist eine Schicht muss und jetzt
die ganzen Tannenzweige
und hier drunter ist jetzt ein schönes
Lager für Holz und wir können starten
alles umräumen bedeutet ich habe mehr
Platz in meinem Tag auch wenn es
tagsüber regnet so wie gerade eben für
mehrere Stunden wo ich nichts machen
konnte habe ich einfach mehr Platz im
Tab und mein Holz bleibt trotzdem
trocken
schaut euch das mal an
die Dinger biegen sich bis zum geht
nicht mehr wir haben richtig Wind
aber eigentlich habe ich hier dieses
Dreier Setup das mich vor all diesen
dünnen Dingern also vor denen hier nicht
dass der könnte genau auf mich drauf
krachen aber dafür steht der Wind in die
falsche Richtung das hier fällt
hoffentlich alles weg von mir also ich
bin ja wirklich überhaupt nicht in
Windrichtung
aber es fühlt sich so an als wäre so
viel Wind dass das schon passieren
könnte Alter das hat gerade wieder so
krank
so krank
und der Regen geht wieder los ich leg
mich ins Zelt ich muss mich ein bisschen
ruhen es bringt alles nichts
das war
der krasseste Donner den ich in meinem
Leben jemals gehört habe aber ich habe
nichts blitzen sehen also es vermutlich
irgendwo ein bisschen
weiter weg
und weil ich jetzt vorerst eh hier
eingesperrt bin
kann ich ja mal kurz darauf eingehen
warum ich glaube in Staffel 1 so
miserabel am Tag eins ausgeschieden zu
sein denn abseits der
generellen Vermutung von außen dass die
Pilze waren oder das irgendwas war war
es eigentlich was anderes ich bin
reingestartet und hab ähnlich wie Fabio
und Martin richtig Magenprobleme beim
Rausgehen gehabt bedeutet Tag eins beim
Aussetzen schon auf dem Truck hinten
sagen wir alle drei Alter uns geht's gar
nicht gut wir lassen uns aussetzen es
regnet ich baue einen miserablen shelter
in die falsche Richtung und mir geht's
schlecht und jetzt kommt der springende
Punkt ich bekomme einfach Schiss ich
hatte Fritz kurze Zeit vorher
kennengelernt und es war eine riesen
Ehre für mich bei so einem Projekt dabei
zu sein ich war unheimlich kleiner
Creator und das hat mir wirklich eine
Menge bedeutet mitmachen zu können und
dann auch mit auf Fritz Kanal
stattfinden zu können und das alles in
Präsentation wo ich da zusammengekauert
saß und
irgendwie mir Kotze hochkam oder ich
wirklich Magenprobleme hatte
hat dazu geführt dass ich dachte ich
kann hier nicht bleiben ich ich muss
sofort weg im Endeffekt habe ich mich zu
Hause hingelegt ausgeschissen
und am nächsten Tag ging es mir schon
viel besser so dass ich garantiert hätte
weitermachen können retrospektiv
ärger ich mich natürlich unheimlich dass
das so passiert ist das war eine absolut
fatale Chance ich habe die Situation
falsch eingeschätzt aber auf der anderen
Seite wusste ich zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht
besser außerdem hat es dazu geführt dass
ich Max und Johannes in den sechs Tagen
wo ich dann komplett draußen waren
nichts auf Social Media und so
kommunizieren durfte wirklich
kennenlernen konnte und das dazu geführt
hat dass ich bei Staffel 2 fürs Teams
mitgeflogen bin und da im Endeffekt was
für größeres draus geworden ist im
Endeffekt war es das Beste was mir
passieren konnte
aber ich kann das natürlich nicht so
stehen lassen und musste es jetzt hier
in diesem Zeit versucht gerade rücken
ich meine ich habe es noch lange nicht
geschafft ich bin noch nicht mal bei der
Hälfte aber
das sind die Gedanken die ich mir über
die letzten Tage hier machen konnte und
man hat eine Menge Zeit sich Gedanken zu
machen was das Ausscheiden in Staffel 1
betrifft und vielleicht schnappe ich mir
die Kamera in den nächsten Tagen noch
mal denn ich habe noch über einige
andere Sachen nachgedacht aber so viel
erstmal zum Ausscheiden von Staffel 1
kann halt auf keinen Fall schlafen weil
in dem Moment wo ich jetzt schlafe
bin ich oh ja toll in dem Moment wo ich
jetzt schlafe schaffe ich es vielleicht
nicht durch die Nacht und da will ich
noch viel weniger wach sein als jetzt
wunderbar
ich denke das einzig schlaue was ich
heute abend abgeben könnte wäre meine
Regenjacke
aber es tut mir nicht alles für die
Punkte es hat endlich endlich aufgehört
zu regnen das lief jetzt quasi den
ganzen Tag
es ist zwar noch hell aber ich will die
Chance nutzen
ist jetzt gerade mal wirklich aufgehört
hat zu regnen den parksack zu packen für
Challenge Tag 3 und ich habe mich
entschieden
was garantiert mit reinkommt mein
Halstuch kommt auf jeden Fall weg habe
ich nicht einmal benutzt nicht gebraucht
bzw wahrscheinlich hätte ich es
gebraucht bei dem Husten den ich gerade
habe aber nicht benutzt und ich denke
ich kann mit dem dicken Pullover den ich
habe jetzt auch weiter durchziehen auch
wenn das mit dem Hals gerade noch etwas
schlimmer wird glaube ich nicht dass es
so schlimm wird dass es mich ausnocken
kann als zweites die Regenjacke einfach
weil ich weiter damit mache mich sofort
und das tat zu verpissen auch wenn es
nur einen Tropfen regnet weil ich
einfach keinen Risiko eingehen und dann
brauche ich die Regenjacke auch nicht
das größte Ziel für mich sind 7 Tage und
habe Hängematte Schlafsack sind so eine
Geisteskranke Kombination gegen Regen
gegen Kälte gegen alles dass ich auf die
Regenjacke verzichten kann aber auf
keinen meiner Gegenstände verzichten
werde auch nicht auf das Messer obwohl
es kaputt ist es ist nach wie vor das
einzige was ich habe was eine Klinge hat
um Sachen zu entasten und so weiter
benutze ich das nach wie vor
es ist kaputt und es ist scheiße aber es
ist besser als nichts und wie gesagt die
einzige Klinge
Gegenstand Nummer 3 mein Gürtel klare
Sache ich behalte das Paracord bin es eh
gewohnt mein Leben lang habe ich
Schnürsenkel als Gürtel genutzt und das
werde ich jetzt die nächsten Tage mit
Paracord genauso weitermachen
zu
und weg
und als letztes schweren Herzens wo ich
dir den ganzen Tag trage meine Mütze das
bedeutet ihr werdet mich die nächsten
Tage nur noch so sehen
aber da müsst ihr dann durch so und hier
noch mal damit ich nachvollziehen können
ich lass den shot durchlaufen Kappe
Halstuch
Gürtel
Regenjacke
meine vier Gegenstände bzw
Kleidungsstücke
ziehen also zusammen
zu
das war's
so
und jetzt die habe ich schon vorbereitet
damit wir die genau auf Länge
abtreten können das hier soll mein
riesiger
tri-pod werden
perfekt
den hier
wunderbar also die sollen sich alle
gegeneinander Stützen alle nach rechts
eigentlich muss ich
außen rum
innen rum außen rum innen rum außen rum
innen rum
denkbar also
ich glaube so wäre das richtige Setup so
guck mal hier das wieder von heute Abend
von den Scheiß Dingern hier
oh die sind wieder überall
da
Proteinquelle
wieder ausspucken vielleicht gar nicht
so schlau die Dinger übertragen ja
glaube ich so ziemlich alles
was gibt ah scheiße
krass
ich habe mich um ehrlich zu sein weil
ich schiss habe und die Dunkelheit
vermeiden will also ich will nicht
wollte die letzten Tage nie sehen wie es
dunkel wird und habe mich deswegen schon
immer ins Tarp gelegt aber vielleicht
bleibe ich heute mal ein bisschen länger
draußen mittlerweile habe ich mich ja
echt gut dran gewöhnt hier zu pennen
und das kann man sich eigentlich nicht
entgehen lassen
[Musik]
ich bin richtig glücklich
ich will gar nicht daran denken was noch
alles kommt
weil es echt
echt noch ein langer Weg ist
aber ich bin schon sehr zufrieden muss
ich wirklich sagen
komplett lost vergessen mich abzumelden
mich einfach ins Bett gelegt Alltag
komplett fertig wie geht's
komplett fertig ist zerrt wirklich
wirklich an den Kräften ich habe mich
gerade eben einfach hier reingelegt bin
schon weggelegt ähm viel rumgesessen
abends geht meine Nase immer wieder zu
bisschen Kopfschmerzen aber Magen immer
noch alles wunderbar und ich will
einfach nur die Nacht rumbekommen und
dann ist alles bestens am Tag viel gegen
Nachmittag haben wir Bergfest was wir
dazu Feier machen weiß ich noch nicht
aber dann sind wir zur Hälfte durch
hammergeil hahaha ich kann es kaum
abwarten gute Nacht
ich habe echt
kein Bock mehr ich will einfach nicht
mehr ich will einfach nicht mehr ich
will nicht mehr nur mit mir alleine sein
ich will wieder mit Leuten reden ich
will Reaktionen auf irgendwas bekommen
das ist ich raste aus Mann der absolute
Horror wirklich das ist ich kann mir
gerade jetzt im Moment nichts
Schlimmeres vorstellen ich habe einfach
keinen Bock mehr und ich will dass es
vorbei geht
[Musik]